something pretty special about getting
on a river
becoming part of his River
you know flowing with the water and to
get in there and an adapter like water
does
but it's not about just sitting in my
kayak and focusing you're getting that
line right but also clearing the lens
figuring out of my camera angles right
making sure how to get the right shot
myself
we're not mainstream athlete where
you're a football player you basically
know what you need to do to be at the
top and to hit the kicks when you have
to being a professional extreme athlete
it's worth a creative performance
activity and that's kind of what we're
doing here right now we're getting
trained to be better at producing our
own content all right sweet so does
everyone here know how to change the
modes on their cameras can I see a
raising hand if anyone doesn't
understand how to change modes all right
it's really difficult when someone does
something really amazing and it's shot
in the not the right mode so we want to
make sure if they're gonna go out and be
doing some of the craziest stuff in the
world we want to make sure that they're
making that look the best so we have a
camera buffet in the back all this gear
is just for you guys to borrow so we
start out with a couple of training
courses in the morning
and then we go out for the day and do
activities you got you got a big Narwhal
wall on the chest cam cool
the game of social media and being an
athlete it's not something to be taken
lightly you could be the world's best at
whatever sport you're doing but if
you're not promoting yourself and no one
sees it then it's hard to make a living
hey GoPro athlete Nick tropen here today
we're gonna do a little bit of a how-to
I'm gonna give you a few quick way it's
not to lose your GoPro and going
kayaking so I'm gonna run a couple of
different options so I'm gonna run a
couple of different options on my hip
you're running a little bit of a
dangerous line when you're tuned like a
passion or a hobby into a full time job
you know because yeah the more you
commit yourself to sponsors and stuff
you find that you actually kayak a
little bit less than four hips yeah you
might necessarily want it an athlete
gets a GoPro they use the GoPro tons of
people watch that footage those people
go and buy GoPros some kid that's never
tried that sport before visor GoPro
makes a video that's the cycle we really
want you might give me a hand just
sliding it down there it can certainly
be overwhelming sometimes having to deal
with a camera but also my own risks but
you know it's it's in the end it makes
it that much more exciting
I think what maybe separates us from
some some other people who do the same
sports there's a certain element I think
of her I don't know if showmanship is
the right word
but we like to share I see someone doing
something that you can tell they love
it's fun to watch I think that's the
goal all of us I'm just trying to
capture those moments and share them
with people and hopefully encourage them
to get outside if you don't have fun
let's not all about work I mean you got
to work sometimes but balance